[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم محمود مراد
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من كييف نتابع هذه
الصور المباشره على واقع اتهامات اوكرانيه
لموسكو بتعمد خلق ازمه جوع عالميه بعد
قصفها مخازن للحبوب في اوديسا جنوبي
البلاد وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي يختتمون قمه
تشاوريه في مدينه جده اكدت على التكامل
الاقتصادي واكلتها قمه مع زعماء دول اسيا
الوسطى بحثت تعزيز العلاقات وتوطيد
الشركات ولي العهد السعودي يؤكد ان
التحديات التي يواجهها العالم تستلزم
تعزيز التعاون وقاده دول اسيا الوسطى
يدعون الى شراكه مع دول الخليج تعزز
الاستثمارات بين الجانبين
في قصف وصفته كييف بالاشد منذ بدء الحرب
روسيا تستهدف اوديسا بالصواريخ والمسيرات
وحديث اوكراني عن تدمير 60 الف طن من
الحبوب وبعد اندلاع حريق في قاعده جويه
بالقرب الكرملين يتهم الغرب بالتغاضي عما
وصفه بالاعمال الارهابيه الاوكرانيه
في حديث علني هو الاول منذ لقائه مع بوتين
بعد عمليه التمرد مؤسس شركه فاجنر يقول
انه وقواته يستعدون في بيلاروسيا لرفع
مستوى الجاهزيه تمهيدا للتوجه الى افريقيا
ويؤكد ان ما يجري على جبهه المعارك في
اوكرانيا عار يجب عدم المشاركه فيه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تعثر
ملف اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
والتحذيرات الدوليه المتداوله المتتاليه
من عدم تمديده على الامن الغذائي العالمي
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا على حضراتكم السؤال التالي ما رايكم
في المسارات المتاحه امام البلدان
المتاثره بعدم تمديد اتفاق الحبوب حتى
الان 60% قالوا انها ستدفعها نحو الضغط
على روسيا بينما راى 40% انها ستسعى
لايجاد بدائل هذا السؤال سابقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على
الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد
يوميا ونتطرق خلاله الى قضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وفي الحصاد ايضا
[موسيقى]
في ضوء مذكرات التوقيف الدوليه بحقه
الرئيس الروسي يشاركه في قمه البريكس
بالجنوب افريقيا عبر الفيديو
يحضر شخصيا
[موسيقى]
انعقدت في مدينه جده اعمال القمه
التشاوريه لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي بحثت
القمه مختلفه القضايا واوضاع المنطقه كما
استضافت المدينه نفسها قمه خليجيه مع قاده
دول اسيا الوسطى اوزباكستان وكازاخستان
وخرزيستان
وتركمانستان وذلك لتعزيز علاقات التعاون
وتاسيس شراكه قويه بين الطرفين
وقال ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان ان التحديات التي تواجه العالم
اليوم تستلزم تعزيز التعاون والاستقرار في
المنطقه واكد الامير محمد بن سلمان في
كلمه له في افتتاح القمه الخليجيه مع قاده
دول اسيا الوسطى على ضروره تكفيف الجهود
المشتركه لمواجهه كل ما يؤثر على امن
الطاقه وسلاسل الامداد
هنا التحديات التي يواجهها عالمنا اليوم
تستلزم بدل جميع الجهود تعزيز التعاون بين
دول وتحقيق الامن والاستقرار في منطقتنا
وفي هذا الشان نؤكد على اهميه احترام
سياده الدول واستقلالها وقيمها وعدم
التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه مرور التكييف
الجهود المشتركه لمواجهه كل ما يؤثر على
امن الطاقه وسلاسل الامداد الغذائيه
العالميه وان نبارك اعتماد خطوط العمل
مشتركه بين مجلس التعاون ودول اسيا الوسطى
لمده 2023
بما في ذلك الحوار السياسي والامني
والتعاون الاقتصادي والاستثماري وتعزيز
التواصل بين الشعوب واقامه شركات فعاله
بين القطاع الاعمال في دول
وخلال كلمته اكد ولي العهد الكويتي ممثل
اميره دوله ممثل وامير دوله الكويت الشيخ
مشعل الاحمد الجابر الصباح اكد اهميه
التشاوري مع الشركاء من اجل مواصله
التعاون وتعزيز الامن والاستقرار كما اعرب
ولي العهد الكويتي عن اماله في تاسيس
شراكه استراتيجيه بين دول مجلس التعاون
ودول اسيا الوسطى
الى مزيد من التعاون في المجالات السياسيه
والامنيه
والاقتصاديه والثقافيه والعلميه والتجاريه
مؤكدين اهميه التشاور المستمر مع شركائنا
من اجل مواصله المزيد من التعاون في كافه
المجالات وتعديل وتعزيز الامن والاستقرار
وتحقيق وتحقيق الازدهار في بلداننا
كما ثمن ممثل سلطنه عمان اسعد بن طارق
خلال اعمال قمه مجلس التعاون لدول الخليج
العربيه ثمن مواقف دول اسيا الوسطى
الداعمه للقضايا العربيه العادله وفي
مقدمتها القضيه الفلسطينيه
اننا نثمن عاليا مواقف دول اسيا الوسطى
الداعمه
للقضايا العربيه العادله وفي مقدمتها
القضيه الفلسطينيه
وضروره نيل الشعب الفلسطيني حقه في تقرير
المصير واقامه دولته المستقله
بعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه وفقا لما نصت عليه
قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه
ومبادره السلام العربيه
وقال رئيس كازاخستان قاسم غومارتو كايز ان
بلاده اقترحت على منظمه شنغهاي للتعاون
عقد منتدى دولي للطاقه في كازاخستان ودعوه
مصدرين النفط والغاز من دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي للمشاركه واضافته كيف في كلمته
انها كازاخستان تطمح الى توسيع علاقاتها
الاقتصاديه مع دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
والدول العربيه نظرا لخبرتها في هذا
المجال
اقترحت مؤخرا في اجتماع لمجلس الرؤساء
الدول الاعضاء لمنظمه الشقاء للتعاون
وقت منتدى دولي للطاقه في كازاخستان
في مجلس التعاون الخليجي للمشاركه في هذا
الحدث
وكما ان مساله الامن الغذائي تعد من
اولوياتنا القصوى من المؤكد ان كازاخستان
تهتم بزياده حجم شاحنات التصدير المنتجات
الزراعيه الى الدول العربيه وتنويه هيكليه
وتعد كازاخستان واحده من اكبر 10 منتجين
للقمح والدقيق في العالم وبالتبع فاننا
نحتاج بشده الى الخبره وقدرات الشركات
العرب في انتاج ومعالجه واعتماد المنتجات
العضويه والمنتجات الحلال
اما رئيس طاجكستان امام علي الرحمن فقال
ان بلاده تبنت منذ استقلالها تعزيز
علاقاتها مع دول الدول الاعضاء في مجلس
التعاون الخليجي واضاف علي الرحمن خلال
القمه الخليجيه التشاوريه بجده ان بلاده
تؤيد اطلاقا مبادره لايجاد حوار استراتيجي
بصيغه اسيا الوسطى الخليج
ان طاجين منذ الايام الاولى لاستقلالها
تبنى التعزيز العلاقات
في مجلس التعاون لدول الخليج العربيه
كواحد من الاتجاهات المهمه في سياسه
الخارجيه ولديها رؤيه ايجابيه لمستقبل هذه
العلاقات وفي هذا السياق نحن نؤيد اطلاق
مبادره ايجاد حوار استراتيجي بصيغه اسيا
الوسطى الخليج ونحن على استعداد لتعزيز
التعاون المثمر في مختلف قطاعات الاقتصاد
والتجاره والاستثمار والثقافه وغيرها من
المجالات ذات الاهتمام المشترك بما في ذلك
في اطار خطه العمل المشترك لفتره
2023 2027
هذا وقال رئيسه تركمانستان سردار باردي
محمد فان التحديات العالميه تستلزم توحيد
الجهود واعتماد حلول مناسبه
من المستحسن انشاء مجلس لوزراء الخارجيه
لدول اسيا الوسطى ودول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي يعمل على اساس دائم ان التطوير
التعاون التجاري والاقتصادي الى جانب
القضايا السياسيه يعتبر من المهام ذات
الاهميه البالغه ويمكن لنا التنويه بان
مجالات النقل والطاقه والاستثمار والتجاره
تعتبر من بين الاتجاهات الاولويه
وبهدف وبهدف تطوير التعاون في هذا
الاتجاهات
كما دعى رئيس اوزباكستان شوكه ميرزايف في
كلمته الدول المشاركه لاتخاذ خطوات فعليه
لمواجهه الاسلام وفوبيا والتطرف والعنصريه
في العالم
ان الزمن نفسه يطلب منا تعزيز تعاوننا في
مجال مكافاه الارهاب والتطرف والعنصريه
وتجارب بالمخدرات والحفاظ على شبابنا من
نشر تلك الاخطار من وسائل من الوسائل
الانترنت
هذا واكد البيان الختمي لقمه الخليج ودول
اسيا الوسطى التي استضافتها جده في
السعوديه اكد على اهميه تعزيز العلاقات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه بين المنطقتين
وعلى استمرار الجهود لتعزيز التعاون
التجاري والاقتصادي وتشجيع الاستثمار
المشترك كما اكد القاده على اهميه استمرار
التعاون في المحافل والمنظمات الدوليه مثل
صندوق النقد الدولي والبنك الدولي لمواجهه
التحديات الاقتصاديه هذا وشدد البيان على
اهميه تطوير طرق النقل بين المنطقتين
وبناء شبكات لوجستيه وتجاريه واعلن القاده
في البيان الختامي دعمهم ترشيح المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لاستضافه معرض معرض
اكسبو 2030 في الرياض
معنى من الرياض السيد سالم اليامي
المستشار السابق في وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه مرحبا بك سيد سالم ما اهميه هذه
القمه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم احييك استاذ محمود
احيي السيدات والساده المشاهدين ويعني
شكري لكريم الاستضافه اهميه هذه القمه في
الحقيقه انها يعني توضح لنا كمراقبين وكل
المتابعين وايضا توضح للدور الاقليميه
والدول العالم ان هناك كتلتين الكتله
الخليجيه بتاريخها وتراثها وبثروتها
بموقعها الجيو استراتيجي وايضا الكتله في
وسط اسيا هذه الدول يعني التي استقلت في
فتره ما من يعني الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
واصبحت دول مستقله وطورت نفسها خلال
العقدين او الثلاثه الماضيه واصبحت قوه
اقتصاديه لديها يعني قوه اقتصاد لديها قوه
بشريه لديها تاثير يعني هي كقوه كمجموعه
في محيطها وفي المحيط الاسيوي والدولي
لقاء هاتين القمتين انا في تقديري هو يكشف
من مج جسور للتعاون لتلافي التحديات وانا
اعتقد ان الكلمات التي استمعنا اليها في
هذه القمه كلها كانت تعول على شيئين تعول
على ضروره ان يكون هناك تعاون وانا
التعاون ربما الذي تم فيه الفترات الماضيه
لم يكن كافيا بالقدر الكافي وهناك رؤى
هناك تطلعات لتعاون جديد وكل ذلك لتلافي
اخبار تحدثت يعني من تحدثوا حقيقه في هذه
القمه بينوا جمله من تلك الاخطار منها
الارهاب منها المخدرات منها يعني التنميه
تحديات التنميه من هالاستقطاب الدولي من
الحروب المنتشره وازمات الطاقه وازمات
الغذاء انا اعتقد ان كل ذلك كان حاضرا في
هذه القمه في تقديرك ما الذي يمكن ان
تستفيده بلدان الخليج العربيه من دول اسيا
الوسطى والعكس
بقى فاقد تعاون بين الجنه
بالنسبه لاولا يعني دعني اخبر حضرتك
والساده المشاهدين انه في يعني ميثاق
الامم المتحده هناك مبدا او بند هو يعني
يركز على ما يسمى به علاقات الصداقه
والتعاون اذا علاقات الصداقه والتعاون هي
مطلوبه من كل المنخرطين في هذه المنظمه
وهذه الدول من ضمنها كما يعني وينطبق الحل
على دول الخليج لكن انا اعتقد ان هناك
ميزات نسبيه وهناك ايضا تتوفر للجانبين
مثل يعني ان هذه البلدان بلدان في بعضها
نفطي وغازي وهذا ايضا مما هو موجود في دول
الخليج هذه الدول يعني تتشارك مع دول
الخليج في المنظور الاسلامي هذه الدول
ربما تكون دعما للمواقف الخليجيه على
مستوى المحافل السياسيه والدوليه يعني اذا
هناك يعني فوائد
اخر يعني المجتمع الدولي اليوم يعني مندفع
الى حاله من كما يقولون تعظيم الفوائد
وتقليل الاخطار ومن الخطا ان تكون هاتين
الكتلتين بالميزات النسبيه لكل منهم ولا
يحدث بينهم التعاون وكما قلت التعاون هو
موجود منذ الاستقلال لكن كان في الاطر
التقليديه اعتقد اليوم هو يشهد دفعه ربما
تنقله الى الامام في تقديرك هل البنيه
القانونيه في بلدان اسيا الوسطى مهيئه
لتدفق استثمارات خليجيه
يعني هناك مشكله انا احييك على هذا السؤال
هناك مشكله في الحقيقه في دول اسيا الوسطى
وهذه المشكله هي ناتجه من يعني ارث طويل
من نظام الحكم الشيوعي تحت الاتحاد
السوفيتي
المعروفه ان هذه البنيه ربما هي الثقافيه
في تقديره الغالبه والتي تتمخض عنها
البنيه القانونيه لكن ما افهمه في الحقيقه
ان هناك تقبل من هذه الدول لتبني قوانين
وانظمه ويعني تشريعات جديده تكون طموحه
وتكون جاذبه ومغريه سواء كان لدول الخليج
او لغيرها لان هناك ايضا استثمارات في هذه
الدول غير الدول الخليج ومن المعروف
حقيقتين ان هناك دول مثل اوروبيه يعني
بدون ذكر الاسماء عندها طموح لكي تستثمر
في هذه الدول ويعني تدفع هذه الدول لتطوير
يعني الياتها القانونيه لتتوائم مع انساق
استثماريه مريحه للجانبين شكرا جزيلا لك
السيد سالم اليامي المستشار السابق في
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه كان معنا من
الرياض شكرا لك
وفي مقابله مع الجزيره قال الامين العام
لمجلس التعاون الخليجي جاسم محمد البديوي
ان هناك اراده واضحه لدى قاده دول الخليج
لتحقيق التكامل الاقتصادي
هنالك عناصر ولله الحمد كبيره ملموسه
واضحه وجليه
للتكاملنا الاقتصادي ولكن هنالك ايضا
عناصر يتوجب
ان نستكمل هكذا اتحاد الجمركي والسوق
الخليجي المشترك حددت رؤيه خادم الحرمين
في التي اطلقت في عام 2015 السقف الزمني
ما بين نهايه 20 24 ونهايه 20 25 تفاهم
ولله الحمد كامل وتام ورغبه جاده وحقيقيه
على مستوى القاده وعلى مستوى الوزراء
للوصول لهذا التكامل الجميع الجميع دون
استثناء يرغب بالوصول لهذا التكامل
الاختلاف قد يكون في بعض المسائل وكيف
التوصل اليها
بلفتوه مشاهدينا الكرام الى ان المقابله
الكامله مع الامين العام لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي جاسم محمد البديوي على شاشه
الجزيره ستبث كامله ضمن برنامج لقاء اليوم
في الساعه الواحده وخمس دقائق بعد منتصف
الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
وصف بيان سعودي تركي مشتركه لاجتماعات
الاخيره بين قيادات البلدين بالمثمره
والمهمه وشملت مجالات تعاون تعاون مختلفه
واشار البيان الذي نشرته وكاله الانباء
السعوديه الى ان الطرفين اتفقا على اهميه
التزام ايران بسلميه برنامجها النووي
والتعاون مع الوكاله الذريه كما اتفق
الطرفان على اهميه استقرار اسواق الطاقه
العالميه وفي الملف الاوكراني اكد
الجانبان على ضروره انهاء الحرب من خلال
المفاوضات واستنادا للقانون الدولي وحول
الصراع في السودان دعت السعوديه وتركيا
الى اتخاذ اجراءات ضروريه لتخفيف معاناه
الشعب السوداني كما دعتا الطرفين
المتنازعين في السودان الى وقف اطلاق
النار والبناء على اعلان الجده
اعلنت الامارات توقيع اتفاقات ومذكرات
تفاهم مع تركيا بقيمه قاربت 51 مليار
دولار بحضور رئيس دوله الامارات الشيخ
محمد بن زايد والرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان الذي وصل الى ابوظبي مساء
الثلاثاء في ختام جوله خليجيه شامله
السعوديه وقطر كما شهد رئيسا البلدين
اعلان اتفاق لانشاء لجنه استراتيجيه
العليا بين تركيا والامارات من جهته قال
وزير الماليه التركي محمد شمشك في تغريده
الله ان الاتفاقات شملت مجموعه من
القطاعات بما في ذلك تمويل الصادرات
وسندات الزلازل والطاقه والدفاع والبنيه
التحتيه والتكنولوجيا والخدمات المصرفيه
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تنفيذ ضربه واسعه
باسلحه جويه وبحريه عاليه الدقه على مواقع
للقوات الاوكرانيه قرب اوديسا من جانبها
اعلنت كيف ان القوات الروسيه تستهدفت
اوديسا ومدنا اوكرانيه اخرى باكثر من 30
صاروخا واشار بيان للقوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه الى استهداف طائرات روسيه
مقاطعه اوديسا بالصواريخ بالاضافه الى
تحليق السراب من المسيرات في اجواء
المدينه وقالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
الضربه الروسيه اليوم استهدفت عمدا محطات
الحبوب لتدمير امكانيه شحن الحبوب
الاوكرانيه ونقلت وكاله رويترز عن وزير
الزراعه الاوكراني ان الهجوم الروسيه تدمر
60 الف طن من الحبوب
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان المياه
الواقعه جنوب شرقي وجنوب غربي البحر
الاسود تم اعلانها مؤقتا مناطق خطره
للملاحه وذلك في اعقاب انتهاء العمل
باتفاق تصدير الحبوب وقالت الوزاره انه
بدءا من الليله سيتم التعامل مع جميع
السفن المبحره الى موانئ اوكرانيه على
البحر الاسود باعتبارها تحمل شحنات عسكريه
وتعليقا على الضربه التي استهدفت اوديسا
قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه انما سمته
الارهاب الروسي في اوديث في اوديثا يثبت
مجددا موسكو خلق ازمه جوع عالميه ومحاوله
اضعاف الحلفاء حسب تعبيرها واعتبر مدير
مكتب زيلينسكي اندري ان من الضروري تجديد
العقوبات على من يساعد موسكو للالتفاف
عليها مؤكدا ان حلفاء كييف واعدائها
وعدوها بحلول للازمه
واضاف ايرماك ان صيغه الرئيس ذا لينسكي
للسلام هي الطريقه الوحيده لانهاء الحرب
وانه يجري العمل مع دول الغرب على فهم
مشترك للصيغه واضاف انه يجب ان تكون روسيا
غير قادره على شان حرب في المستقبل ويمكن
ضمان ذلك من خلال العقوبات الاقتصاديه
واستخدام اصولها لاعمار اوكرانيا
معنى من نيويورك السيده ايزابيل كولمان
نائبه مديره الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه
الدوليه سيده ايزابيل مرحبا بك هل ترين ان
قرار روسيا وقف العمل باتفاقيه تصدير
الحبوب يعيد الى العالم شبح الازمه
الغذائيه العالميه والارتفاع الحاد في
الاسعار الذي كان قائما قبل اقرار هذا
الاتفاق قبل عام
شكرا على هذا السؤال لقد شاهدنا الاسواق
او رد الاسواق وتفاعل الاسواق بطريقه
مستقره بعد هذه الانباء بانسحاب روسيا يوم
امس ارتفعت الاسعار قليلا في الاسواق
العالميه ولكن بعد ذلك عادت الاسعار الى
مستوياتها السابقه لذلك لا اعتقد ان
الازمه هي اليوم ولكن اخشى ان الازمه سوف
تاتي في المستقبل ما تقوم به روسيا هو
انها بشكل متعمد تدمر القدرات الزراعيه
لاحدى الدول التي فيها سله غذائيه اهم
بالعالم وهذا سوف يكون لديه تبعات اشهر
وسنوات ولذلك العالم يجب ان يقلق ايذاء
الامن الغذائي وهناك دول في افريقيا كينيا
على سبيل المثال الحكومه الكينيه قالت ان
هذا التصرف من جانب بوتين بالانسحاب من
مباد الحبوب هي طعنه في ظهر الامن
الغذائيه وهو لخص هذا الموقف لخص الحقيقه
التبعات السيئه للغايه على الامد البعيد
بالنسبه
للدول الاكثر هشاشه سوف يؤدي ذلك في نهايه
المطاف الى الرفع الاسعار
والجهات الاكثر هشاشه بنسبه الى الامن
الغذائي هي التي سوف تعاني باكبر قدر هل
صحيح ان اوضاعا صعبه تنتظر دولا في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط مثل مصر والاردن ولبنان
واليمن والسودان جراء
الانسحاب روسيا من الاتفاق
ان هذه الحقيقه لسوء الحظ من المرجح
للغايه بان الاوقات الصعبه سوف تاتي في
المستقبل لقد شاهدنا بلدان مختلفه لديها
مستويات مرتفعه من المحاصيل وهو ما حافظ
على استقرار الاسعار هي عاده وتراجعت ب
25% من اعلى مستوياتها ولكن العالم على
مسار الازمه لقد شاهدنا الاحترار العالمي
التغير المناخي والتبعات هذا التغير
المناخي وبالتالي عدد من البلدان المصدره
اذا ما عانت من جفاف او من كوارث طبيعيه
ذلك يضغط على الامن الغذائي وكما سبق
واسلفت اوكرانيا هي من اكبر السلات
الغذائيه او الخبز في العالم على وجه
الخصوص هذا التدمير
تعمد لي قدرات اوكرانيا الزراعيه من قبل
روسيا سوف يكون لديه تبعات على الامد
البعيد هذا الاتفاق يفترض انه كان قائما
على منافع متبادله لكل الاطراف او متحققه
لكل الاطراف روسيا تشكو من ان الجزء الخاص
بصادراتها من الاسمده
ووارداتها من قطع الغيار
والالات الزراعيه لم يتحقق لماذا لم ياخذ
الغرب بعين الاعتبار الازمه الغذائيه
العالميه ويرفع القيود عن روسيا في هذه
المجالات وكذلك يسمح باعاده ربط البنك
الزراعي الروسي بنظام سويفت العالمي
للتحويلات الماليه
يؤسفني ان اقول ولكن توصيف توتن بالنسبه
الى ما حصل مع روسيا في مبادره البحر
الاسود هي اكاذيب هو اكاذيب ان روسيا حققت
صادرات تاريخيه قياسيه العام الماضي وفي
هذا العام الغذاء
والاسمده غير خاطئه للعقوبات تمكنت روسيا
من تصدير القمح والحبوب والاسمده كما سبق
واستلفت نتحدث عن مستويات قياسيه العام
الماضي وهذا العام نحن نتحدث اذا عن
محاوله متعمده من قبل الروس بتدمير قدرات
اوكرانيا لكي تزيد حصه روسيا من الاسواق
في العالم وبالتالي طريقه توصيف بوتين هي
محض اكادير ما البدائل المتاحه اذا لم
تتراجع روسيا عن قرارها هل يمكن الاستمرار
في شحن الحبوب من الموانئ الاوكرانيه في
ظل ارتفاع تكلفه تامين السفن وهي اصلا
كانت مرتفعه
صعوبتي بمكان بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا ان
تتمكن من استبدال لطريقه التصدير من البحر
الاسود لان السفن هي اكثر الطرق فعليه ومن
حيث التكلفه كذلك الافضل لنقل البضائع نحن
نعمل مع الاوروبيين لكي نتعاون مع
اوكرانيا كي تصل الى امكانيه التصدير من
خلال طرق بديله من خلال بولندا التنوب عبر
رومانيا ولكن نحن نتحدث عن صفعه كبيره
للامن الغذائي العالمي ان يتطلب كل هذا
الجهد لتصدير الحبوب بعد القرار الروسي
امل هناك محادثات او احاديث عن عوده روسيا
الى هذا الاتفاق وامل ان يحصل ذلك اذا
ذكرتي مسارين مختلفين يمكن من خلالهما
تصدير الحبوب عبر بولندا وعبر رومانيا لكن
المزارعين المحليين في هذين البلدين
يعترضون على دخول الحبوب ومنتجات المواد
الغذائيه الاوكرانيه نظرا لانها تؤثر على
الاسعار في تلك البلدان وتؤثر بالتالي على
مداخيلهم لماذا لا تقدم منح لهؤلاء
المزارعين حتى يمكن استرضائهم وتمر شحنات
الحبوب الاوكرانيه بسلام الى الدول
المحتاجه
شاهدنا من بعض الاعتراضات لان بعض الحبوب
التي مرت بهذه البلدان بقيت في البلدان
واثرت على الاسعار ولكن الان جهود اكبر
تبذل لكي تمر الحبوب عبر هذه البلدان
وتشحن الى الخارج ونامل ان هذه الطريقه
سوف تخفف من هذه المشكلات ما امكانيه
التغلب على العوائق اللوجستيه ويتم من
خلال سكك الحديديه ربط السكك الحديديه
الاوكرانيه بنظيرتها في بقيه دول اوروبا
من خلال تغيير مقاسات السكك هذه انا اعلم
انها مختلفه بعض الشيء بين اوكرانيا وبين
تلك البلدان هل يمكن التغلب على هذه
العوائق بانشاء خطوط سكه حديد بديله من
خلالها يتم تصدير هذه الكميات الهائله من
المواد الغذائيه من اوكرانيا الى بقيه
الدول العالم
الوكاله الامريكيه اللي هي التنميه
الدوليه كجهدا من جهود الحكومه الامريكيه
عملت لاكثر من سنه لكي تؤمن
تيسير تسطير الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر
الدانوب وعبر الممرات البريه ونحن نعمل
على هذه المساله اشرتم اليها بالنسبه الى
المقاييس المختلفه او المقاسات المختلفه
المرتبطه بسكك الحديد يجب التطرق ومعالجه
هذه النقاط بالاضافه الى زياده القدره
الاستيعابيه او القدره الطاقه للعمل
الجمارك
والمعاينه
للجهات التي تشحن الحبوب زياده الطاقه
للعملي 24 ساعه في اليوم سبعه ايام في
الاسبوع المرور عبر نهر الدانوب وبالتالي
رفع القدره على العمل وش نتائج ايجابيه في
حقيقه الامر القدره على استخدام هذه الطرق
البديله لقد بدا ذلك نتحدث عن اربعه الاف
بالمئه هذه النسبه
وهذا ما شاهدناه ولكن كما سبق واستلفت هذا
يؤدي الى صرف مبالغ اضافيه ووقت اضافي
طبعا مسار البحر الاسود هو المفضل من حيث
التكلفه
للقيام بعمليات تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
من خلال هذا البحر البحر الاسود الى
العالم ولكننا نعاين ونعمل مع الاوروبيين
ونتاكد من ان اوكرانيا لديها كل الفرص لكي
تتمكن من تصدير القمح والزيوت الى كل
العالم كل الحبوب التي تصدرها اوكرانيا
اذهب نائبه مديره الوكاله الامريكيه
للتنميه الدوليه كانت معنا من نيويورك
شكرا جزي لا لك
اندلع حريق في قاعده عسكريه بمنطقه
كيروفيسكي في شبه جزيره القرم التحقيقات
ستحدد اسباب هذا الحريق اتخذت قرارا
باجلاء نحو 2200 شخص من سكان اربع بلدات
في المنطقه كما تم ايضا وقف الحركه على
طريق تغريده ونشرنا مسار الطريق البديل
المؤقت لم نسجل اي اصابات حتى الان وادعو
الجميع الى التحلي بالهدوء والاسترشاد
حصرا بمصادر المعلومات الرسميه
اذا تلفت هذه الاستهدافات بين الروس
والاوكرانيين الانظار الى الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لكل طرف وتاثيرات هذه
الضربات على مسار المعارك
[موسيقى]
معركه الموانئ في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
هذا ما يبدو عليه الامر خلال اليومين
الماضيين تضرب القوات الروسيه مواقع
للقوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه اوديس جنوبيه
البلاد تلك مقاطعه تحوي اهم موانئ
اوكرانيا حتى خلال الحرب الحاليه من هناك
تتحرك الحبوب الاوكرانيه نحو العالم وفق
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب تقول رئاسه الاوكرانيه
ان الضربات الروسيه استهدفت عمدا محطات
الحبوب لتدمير امكانيه شحن الحبوب
الاوكرانيه تتهم روسيا بتعمد خلق ازمه جوع
عالميه ومحاوله اضعاف الحلفاء يذهب وزير
الزراعه الاوكراني نحو التفاصيل اكثر
ليقول ان تلك الضربات دمرت 60 الف طن من
الحبوب بناء على هذه الاتهامات تطالب كييف
بتجديد العقوبات على روسيا ومن يساعدها في
الالتفاف على العقوبات المفروضه الضربات
الروسيه جاءت بعد ساعات من ضربات اوكرانيه
استهدفت مواقع عسكريه الروسيه في شبه
جزيره القرد يقول الروس ان الاوكرانيين
استهدفوا ميناء سيفاستوبول الاستراتيجي
مقر اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي في شبه
الجزيره التي تسيطر عليها روسيا منذ 2014
وتعتبرها اوكرانيا جزءا من اراضيها لا
يمكن التنازل عنه بالتقادم هكذا تحولت
الموانئ على الشواطئ الشماليه للبحر
الاسود الى عنوان معركه جديده في حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا فهل من بديل تبدو
الطرق البريه بديلا ممكلا لرحله الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر اوروبا الى العالم بدل
الرحله البحريه المختصره الى اسطنبول
ومنها الى العالم لكن الرحله البريه هذه
ستكون اطول من حيث المسافه والمده الزمنيه
لوصول الحبوب بالاضافه الى الكميات التي
تحملها السفن من الحبوب فتحتاج الى شاحنات
اكثر بكثير لحمل نفس الكميه عبر البر
معركه الموانئ تتخذ شكل عض الاصابع الان
لكن اثارها تتجاوز حدود اوكرانيا وحرب
روسيا عليها عاد الخوف من توسع رقعه
المجاعه في كثير من الدول بعد وقف العمل
باتفاق الحبوب الاخير الموقع بين روسيا
واوكرانيا برعايه امميه ذلك اتفاق فتح
الباب امام وصول ثلاثه وثلاثين مليون طن
من الحبوب منذ اغسطس الماضي بعد توقيع
الاتفاق هذه حبوب وصلت الى دول تحتاجها
بشكل اساسي ومنها دول يعيش ملايين الناس
فيها تحت خط الفقر
ويتهددهم الجوع بعد وقف الاتفاق ارتفعت
فعلا اسعار العقود الاجله للحبوب خصوصا من
القمح والذره بحسب وكاله بلومبرج لهذا كله
لا يمكن النظر الى المواقع المستهدفه في
الحرب بمعزل عن اهميتها الاستراتيجيه لكلا
الطرفين وتاثير استهدافها على مسار الحرب
وحلفاء لكل ضعف
معنى من موسكو
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي والضابطه
الاحتياطي في الجيش الروسي ومن كييف السيد
يوري ساك مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ويبدا من ضيفنا في موسكو هل هناك تفسير
لاستهداف او الاستهداف المتعمد كما يقول
الجانب الاوكراني لمحطات تصدير الحبوب في
اوديسا بعد يوم واحد او بعد يومين من
اعلان روسيا انها لن تمدد العمل باتفاق
تصدير الحبوب هل من تفسير لهذا الامر
مساءكم طيب قبل اي شيء اريد ان انبه ان
الضربات كانت ضد اهداف عسكريه
وكانت هذه بنيه تحتيه عسكريه بحريه وكان
هناك
مستودعات للذخيره ومصانع حيث تصنع او
توسان
تسمى بالمسيرات المائيه
واذا كان هناك منشاه مدنيه قد دمرت فهذه
ضياعات
وامور تحدث اثناء الحرب ولكنها تكون رمزيه
لان السيد بوتين حدد بوضوح انه اذا ما قام
الغرب بالالتزام بشروط مبادره نقل الحبوب
فعندها سوف تعود روسيا
للمفاوضات بالنسبه لهذا الاتفاق فما هو
المعنى من تدمير البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
موانع اذا ما كان الرئيس قد قال انه سوف
يعود للاتفاقيه والمبادره اذا كانت الشروط
مناسبه
طيب سيد يري ساك في المقابل فان الجانب
الاوكراني لم يدخر جهدا وقصف هو الاخر
مواقع في شبه جزيره القرم رغم التحذير
الروسي المتكرر من استهداف هذه المناطق هل
نفهم ذلك في اطار رغبه اوكرانيه في تصعيد
الحرب او الضغط على روسيا للعوده مجددا
الى اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
اسعدتم مساءا نمد ان ندفع روسيا ليس
العوده الى الاتفاق بدنا ندفعها لتعود الى
روسيا لان هذه المره اثبت تبوتي مره اخرى
بانهم يرتكبون اعمال ارهابيه ضد البنى
التحتيه
المدنيه السيد الذي ملابس عسكريه
يقول كلاما غير معقولا فهذا فما جرى
استهدافه كان ضد الموانع بهدف ايقاف
الصادرات الحبوب من اوكرانيا والتي مهمه
جدا لكل عالم
لتجنب ازمه غذائيه ان ما نريد نحو اخراج
هؤلاء المجرمين حرب من بلادنا وتقديمهم
الى محكمه المحكمه جنائيه الدوليه
وبالتالي هم ليس لديهم اي حق اخلاقي او
قانوني لفتح افواههم والتحدث عن قانون
دولي او اهداف مشروعه فهم بلد ودوله
عدوانيه ورئيسهم ودينك مجرم حرب فماذا
يمكن يقول لك مذكره دوليه لتوقيف الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين لكن هذا لا يعني ادانته
سيعود للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لازداد
القرار لكن الشهاده نحن نشاهدنا يوميا
البشعات الجرائم الحرب التي يتخذها
يرتكبها جوده
بنسبه لنا ليس لدينا اي شيء ونعتقد ان
محكمه جنائيه الدوليه ايضا لا تجد اي
صعوبه في ايجاد ادله على ذلك لاننا لحد
الان وثقنا اكثر من 90 الف جريمه حرب
والرئيسيه منها هي
مقامت به القوات الروسيه رئيسها الرئيس
بوتين ثم حصل في 24 فبراير كان
انتهاك الميثاق المتحده وجريمه حرب
وانتهاك لكل القوانين الدوليه سيد فاسيلي
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت انه بدءا من
الليله سيتم التعامل مع جميع السفن
المبحره من موانئ اوكرانيه على البحر
الاسود على انها تحمل شحنات عسكريه
جدير بالذكر او غني عن الذكر ان نقول ان
هذه الموانئ اصلا مخصصه لتصدير الحبوب بل
مسوغ لاستهداف هذه المنطقه مناطق الصراع
وجبهات الصراع كثيره جدا لماذا استهداف
هذه المنطقه وانت تعرف ان هناك ازمه غذاء
عالميه موجوده بالفعل يفاقمها هذا
الاستهداف
شخصيا تابع لوزاره الدفاع وانا ضابط بل
انا ضابط بحري واعلم وافهم جيدا عن ماذا
نتحدث بالنسبه لنا قبل كل شيء من المهم
انه في اوكرانيا تحت غطاء مبادره البحر
الاسود ان لا يصل السلاح الى اوكرانيا
ونحن نعلم كيف نعيق هذا لذلك بما اننا
خرجنا من هذه المبادره واعلنا ان الطرق
غير امنه للسفن في البحر الاسود واعلنا
اننا لن نضمن امن السفن التي سوف تتوجه
الى الموانئ البحر الاسود التي تقع تحت
سيطره اطراف الاوكراني هذا يعني اننا سوف
نشك بهذه السفن وانها قد تكون تحمل
الاسلحه وسوف نعتبرها اهدافا شرعيه هذا
ليس له اي دخل
باعاقه الاعمال الاغاثيه او الضرر بالبنيه
التحتيه بالطبع هذا سوف يوقف الاعمال
التجاريه وهذا لان الشروط الروسيه في
المبادره لم يقم احد بتنفيذها ولا احد
يدافع عن مصالح روسيا لذلك منذ الساعات
الاولى منذ ساعات الاولى من هذه الليله
وبعد دقائق اي سفينه سوف تتوجه لموانئ
البحر الاسود الاوكرانيه سوف تكون اهدافا
شرعيه للقوات البحريه الروسيه سيدوري الى
اي مدن يمكن ان يؤثر ذلك على وفاء الدول
الغربيه بوعودها امداد اوكرانيا باسلحه
حديثه
هل هناك مسارات اخرى لهذه الاسلحه لكي
تدخل الى اوكرانيا واستفيد منها الجيش
الاوكراني غير موانئ البحر الاسود
مع كل الاحترام اود منك ان لا تفسيره او
تفهم الامور على وجهها لان لك هذه سمعتها
من ضيفكم بان ان هذا ان هذا امر كل الذي
قاله كذب وارجل لا تكرر الكذب على
التلفزيون وهذا اولا وثانيا ليس لك اي
علاقه بين صفقه الحبوب والمساعدات
العسكريه تقدم لاوكرانيا من قبل الحلفاء
الغرب كل حلفاؤنا الغربيين يفهمون جيدا
ويرون بامه عينهم يوميا نوع العدو الذي
نتعامل معه والان انت سمعت قبل قليل ممثل
هذه النظام الارهابي يهدد العالم كله
بالسفن العالم المختلفه بالتدمير والدمار
اذا ما حملوا الحبوب اليس هذا نظاما
ارهابيا اعتقد كل الناس سمعوا مقاله
باذانهم او اكد لكم ان الغربيين يفهموننا
نتعامل مع نظام ارهابي وهم سيواصلون
للتقديم الدعم العسكري لنا الذي نحتاجه
للحاق الهزيمه عبر في ساحه المعارك ثم
تقديرهم الى العداله شكرا جزيلا لك مستشار
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني والمتحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه كان معنا من كيف
واشكر كذلك ضيفنا من موسكو السيد باسيلي
فاتيجاروف الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
والضابط الاحتياطي في الجيش الروسي شكرا
لكما
[موسيقى]
قال قائد مجموعه فاغنر في تسجيل منسوب له
انما يحدث في اوكرانيا عار يجب عدم
المشاركه فيه واضاف ان قوته ستبقى في
بيلاروسيا لبعض الوقت متعهدا بجعل الجيش
البيلاروسي الثانيه اقوى جيش في العالم
حسب قوله واشار بريكوزن الى ان مقاتلي
فاجنر يرفعون من جاهزيتهم استعدادا للتوجه
الى افريقيا
ماذا حل بها وبهم بعد التمرد الفاشل منتصف
شهر الماضي تطارد تساؤلات فاجنر وقادتها
ومقاتلها
منحو ضماناتنا امنيه بموجب اتفاق حققته
البيلاروسيه لكنهم لم ياخذوا جميعا المسلك
ذاته فهل هي بدايه التشضي
ثمه اصحاب خيار البقاء اما للاندماج في
القوات النظاميه او العوده للحياه المدنيه
هم انفسهم من سلموا موسكو اسلحه ومعدات
عسكريه شمل الدبابات وعظمه صواريخ واكثر
من الفي طن من الذخيره وهم من اقترح
الرئيس الروسي قائدا جديدا لهم وليفاجنر
يلقب بيدي الشعر الرمادي انه العقيد
المتقاعد
الذي شارك في حروب الشيشان وافغانستان
وسوريا
الفريق الاخر الذي اثر المغادره الى
بيلاروسيا مع قائد المجموعه
له اجنده مختلفه
غير بعيد عن الحدود مع اوكرانيا يطلع
هؤلاء بمهمه تدريب قوات الدفاع الاقليميه
يتعهد
بجعل الجيش البيلاروسي ثاني اقوى جيش في
العالم ويقول انما يحدث في اوكرانيا عار
يجب عدم المشاركه فيه
ومع ذلك فليس واضحا ما اذا كان دور
الميليشيا في الحرب على اوكرانيا قد انتهى
ام انه يتم الاعداد لفتح جبهه جديده في
الصراع ولم يتضح بعد ايضا مدى صحه تصريحات
نائب روسي قال ان الرئيس بوتين يحضر لهجوم
على بولندا بمقاتله فاجنر انطلاقا من
بيلاروسيا
ماذا الان عن مجمل عمليات فاغنر في الخارج
لطالما اتهمت المجموعه بتنفيذ ما وصفت
بمهمات قذره خلال مشاركتها في عمليات
قتاليه بمناطق نزاع في كل من افريقيا
واسيا وامريكا اللاتينيه منذ 2016 سجلت
نشاطات في ليبيا لدعم اللواء المتقاعد
خليفه حفتر كما انتشرت الميليشيا في
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وفي السودان منذ
2017 تحت غطاء شركات التنقيب عن الذهب كما
تنتشر في مدغشقر وموزمبيق وكذلك في مالي
بعد انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه منها والان لا
يخفي فرع المجموعه المتمركز مع قيادته
القديمه في بيلاروسيا بان العمليات
العابره للحدود ستستمر بل ان مقاتليه
يرفعون من جاهزيتهم كما قيل للتوجه حصرا
الى القاره الافريقيه
[موسيقى]
فقره المتابعه في حصاد الليله نخصصها
لمذكره الاعتقال الدوليه الصادره بحق
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وتاثيرها
المفترض على قراره عدم المشاركه في قمه
التي تلتئم الشهر المقبله في جنوب افريقيا
فقد قاطعت موسكو الشك باليقين باعلان
الكريملين ان بوتين لن يسافر الى
جوهانسبرج لحضور قمه ال15 من 22 اغسطس
المقبل وحتى الرابع والعشرين منه ورغم
توجيهها دعوه له للحضور ساعه جنوب افريقيا
منذ شهور لاقناع بوتين بعدم المشاركه
لانها ستكون ملزمه في هذا هذه الحاله
باعتقاله باعتبارها دوله موقعه على النظام
الاساسي للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وواجهت
جوان سبيرج ضغوطا مزدوجه اولاها غربيه
ودوليه لتنفيذ مذكره الاعتقال بحق بوتين
وثنيها من روسيا التي حذرتها من ان اعتقال
رئيسها ربما يعني اعلان حرب عليها
سيكتفي بوتين بالمشاركه في القمه عبر
تقنيه الفيديو وفق ما اعلن عنه المتحدث
باسم الكريم بينما سيتراس وزير الخارجيه
سيرجينا الوفد الروسيه الى الجنوب افريقيا
مذكره الاعتقال التي يبدو انها ذات تاثير
فعليا على بوت اصدرتها المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه في شهر مارس اذار الماضي بتهمه
ارتكاب جرائم جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا على
راسها خطف اطفال اوكرانيين ونقلهم الى
روسيا مازق الدول مع مذكرات المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه مازق قديم وادى في مرات
كثيره الى ازمات دبلوماسيه لاسيه ما عندما
يتعلق الامر بدول مواقعه على قانون
المحكمه جنوب افريقيا نفسها واجهت ازمه
مماثله عام 2015 عندما رفضت اعتقال الرئيس
السوداني انذاك عمر البشير المطلوب
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه حيث تعرضت
لانتقادات حاده مئه
وثلاثه وعشرون دوله وقعت على ميثاق الجنا
ئيه الدوليه وهي معرضه لمثل تلك المازق
لانها ملزمه قالونا باعتقال اي مطلوب
للعداله الدوليه بصرف النظر عن منصبه او
حصلته اصدرت المحكمه عده مذكرات اعتقال
لكنها لم تتمكن من مقاضات سوى عدد قليل من
المتهمين ابرزهم الرئيس الصربي الراحل
السودان الذي يعتبر اول رئيس دوله في
العالم يمثل امام هيئه المحكمه في لهااي
عام 2001
بالاضافه الى رئيس صرب البوسنه رادوفان
كرديه الذي اعتقل في بلغراد عام 2008
بعدما امضى اكثر من 12 سنه متواريا عن
الانظار معنى من تورنتو ضيفنا ضيفنا السيد
شيلي
رئيس الرئيس السابق للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه سيد اوسجي مرحبا بك صحيح ان
الازمه مرت باعلان روسيا عدم المشاركه من
قبل الرئيس بوتين ولكن عبر تقنيه الفيديو
لكن اثار هذا هذه الازمه اثرت من جديد
الجدل حول مدى تاسيس المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه واستخدامها من قبل الغرب ورقه
لملاحقه او الضغط على رؤساء لا ترضى عنهم
مثل عمر البشير والرئيس بوتين ما مدى
وجاهت هذه الاتهامات
شكرا على هذا السؤال الذي
طرحتموه بالنسبه الى ما
تفضلتم بعرضه
وصولا الى السؤال اذا كان هناك كما اشرتم
قضيه
وهي القضيه التي نظرت فيها
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
وادت ايضا الى محاكمته
محاكمته في السابق وكان جزءا من
محكمه
يوغوسلافيا بالتحديد
وايضا هناك قضيه سيراليون اذا بالنسبه الى
الماضي الان لدينا الرئيس الروسي وفي
الماضي الرئيس
السودان عمر البشير والذي
تمت ادانته لاحقا في البدايه ظن الناس ان
ذلك لن يؤدي الى النتيجه المرجوه ولكننا
نرى ان العمليات الدوليه التي تعمل من
خلالها المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه تؤدي الى
النتائج لدي صعوبه بقبول
الحجه بان الغرب يسيس المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه حيث انه ليس فقط الدول الغربيه هي
التي تحاول ان تسيس او تستفيد من الجهات
الدوليه والهيئات الدوليه من اجل امورك
وغايات سياسيه عدد كبير من الدول يحاول ان
يقوم بذلك ولكن من الاهميه بمكان الا يسمح
المجتمع الدولي
بذلك ان يتم تسييس هذه الهيئات يمكن ان
نقول ان البعض يحاول ان يستفيد من هذه
الحجه لكي يتفلت من مواجهه العقاب
والمحاكمه
ونحن نرى ان العداله بالنسبه الى عمليات
واجراءات المحكمه الجنائيه الدوريه هي
الاساس تقول انك تجد صعوبه في فهم
الاتهامات بتسييس عمل المحكمه لكن اخرون
ايضا يجدون صعوبه في فهم ما تفهمه انت او
في فهم ما تجده صعبا يعني على سبيل المثال
تم غزو العراق بالمخالفه للقانون الدولي
ولقي اكثر من مليون شخص حتفهم غالبيتهم
مدنيون ومع ذلك لم نرى مذكره اعتقال لا
بحق الرئيس جورج بوش ولا بحق رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني توني بلير
هذه ليست
مشكله
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه هذه الحجه التي
اشرتم اليها تقضي
ببسطيط الضوء على موضوع النفاق او الكيل
بمكيالين اذا يمكن النظر بهذه الحجه او
بهذا التفصيل ولكن بالنسبه الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه هي محكمه قائمه
جهات مختلفه لا تسمح للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه ان تؤدي عملها المطلوب بسبب
السياسات الخاصه بالدول ان المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه استحدثت والان اصبح
لدينا مسارا
للتعامل مع هذه السلوكيات المختلفه اذا
نحن بحاجه للسماح لعمليات واجراءاتي
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بان تتم بشكل
جيد عوضا عن التركيز عن الامور الماضيه
عندما نتحدث عن التاريخ من بين مباعث
القلق المرتبطه
بالمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه هي تركيز على
جزء من العالم ومحاكمه اشخاص من جزء من
جزء العالم جزء محدد ولكن دعونا نتذكر ان
المحكمه
تتعامل
وتصدر مذكرات التوقيف بنيه
المحاكمه
وفي العام
في التسعينيات اذا ايضا كان هناك مثال
في المانيا اذا
بان في العام 1919 في الماضي هذا في
التاريخ واذا ما عدنا الى سنه 1945
ايضا كان هناك
نيه بمحاكمه قائد ولكنه
شكرا جزيلا لك السيد شيلي
الرئيس السابق للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
كان معنا من تورنتو شكرا لك
الحصاد تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]